foreign
console stepping out to the sounds of a
traditional Yorkshire Brass Band and a
warm welcome
seen in public for the first time since
news of a new title for Camilla
one confirmed cemented and celebrated on
this coronation invitation sent on
behalf of their Majesty's King Charles
III and queen Camilla
people who Brave the weather to see them
in Malton today so it's a moment she
deserves I agree with it yes it's yeah
it's right she is his Queen isn't she
she's Our Queen so
I think she's earned it I think it's
it's his choice it's his wife and she
should be able to beat the Queens it
will be quite different really it's
going to be really weird yeah no but I
think
I mean she's married to the king so yeah
I mean it is what it is
new for the country so yeah for experts
this is simply about following tradition
this shift is actually kind of going to
be her her proper title if we can call
it that because we talk about King
Charles so it's natural to say queen
Camilla rather than Queen consort and
you only have to look back to the Queen
Mother Queen Mary Queen Alexandra before
that and it's just the normal way that
Queen's consult are referred to
it's a time that has heralded so much
change but with this certainty and
clarity
from the day they're crowned they will
simply be the king and queen
shinki marike Sky News molten in North
Yorkshire